the best DC movie yet sir a soul-sucking
Vortex of mediocrity Twitter users have
given their unfiltered reviews of The
Flash and they didn't hold back
ever since Warner Brothers Discovery got
serious about building a shared DC film
Universe numerous heroes and villains
have received individual live-action
movies Wonder Woman Shazam Aquaman and
more have taken the Silver Screen by
storm well at long last a Scarlet
speeder has zoomed into Cinemas for a
theatrical Adventure on his own a solo
Adventure shares with Supergirl an
alternate universe version of Barry
Allen and Ben Affleck and Michael
Keaton's respective takes on Batman
let's get nuts how's this a trend in
superhero media at the moment the flash
is a Multiverse tale through and through
and Barry takes it upon himself to
rewrite history he mistakenly causes
multiple timelines to converge on one
another to disastrous effect versus his
job to restore order to the Multiverse
by any means necessary this premise and
its execution led to Rotten Tomatoes
being filled with mixed reviews from
critics who got to see the movie early
now that online assessments of the film
are joined by those of fans who wasted
no time checking it out with the
theatrical run of the flash officially
underway here's what some of the first
moviegoers to see it had to say about it
despite endorsements from the likes of
James Gunn and Stephen King tells him
yet as a be-all and end-all comic book
movies out of its Premiere many DC fans
feel that the Flash doesn't make it
anywhere close to that level suffice to
say they weren't afraid to dive into why
one user said just watch The Flash
pretty mediocre at times and really bad
most of the other times it's like a 4
out of 10. I can't say I liked anything
about the movie even though I am really
trying to find something redeeming about
her another fan wasn't impressed by the
film either claiming that not even the
copious Easter eggs could save the poor
dialogue story and CGI meanwhile the
third Twitter user who to be fair tend
to give over-the-top reviews wrote The
Flash is a soul-sucking vortex of wasted
potential and creative bankruptcy I knew
you were going to say this yes even
though the title of the movie is The
Flash one fan feels the only good part
of the movie is Michael Keaton's Batman
speaking of supporting characters
another user who also didn't care for
the CGI and overall narrative believes
the feature doesn't do nearly enough
with Supergirl of course even as a good
chunk of the DC fandom to the social
media to dunk on the flash for one
reason or another many still took to
Twitter with supporting comments on the
film modern fun came up with quite a
positive review tweeting The Flash is
the movie event of the Year action
emotion and story is the best in the
dceu Ezra Miller is great Michael Keaton
stands out in his scenes there are so
many Easter eggs that DC fans will love
and that's ending Cameo so unexpected
but worth it another user found the
flash to be a top tier Multiverse story
and while they admitted that it's far
from perfect a third fan appreciated the
movie's blend the fun and emotion one
fan who caught the film even compared it
to some of the most influential
superhero movies of time Rising The
Flash is the greatest dceu era movie of
the more it's like some Remy Spiderman 2
had a baby with the Batman 89 with the
heart and sincerity as Superman 78
foreign
taking these fan reactions into
consideration it seems that the flash
will prove yet another polarizing entry
into the DC adaptation Library it's
currently playing exclusively in
theaters so you can check it out for
yourself
foreign
[Music]